One way of coping with scale, is to
introduce hierarchy. OSPF has a notion of areas, and
ISIS has an analogous notion of levels. In a
backbone network, the network's routers may be divided into
levels, or areas. And the backbone, itself, may
have its own area. In OSPF, the backbone area
is called area zero, and each area in the
backbone that's not in area zero has an area
zero router. The area zero routers perform
shortest path computation. And the routers in
each of the other areas independently perform
shortest path computation. Now paths are computed by
computing the shortest path within an area. Or, if the path must leave an area,
it's computed by stitching together the shortest
path to the area zero backbone router, and
then the shortest path across area
zero, followed by another intra-area shortest path.